one of my earliest memories is seeing
The Lion King and being absolutely
traumatized when Mufasa spoiler alert
gets killed by the Stampede that had a
massive fan effect on me and showing me
like how much a 2d cinema screen can
make you feel so much we did a screening
of get out in 2017 at the end of the
film there was this massive voluptuous
Applause in the cinema again it was just
like he made the hairs on the backy neck
stand up that is such a special and
unique thing that only exists in cinemas
I think that human beings are supposed
to go to cinema I think it's intrinsic
to who we are it's something about
coming together be it round of fire or
in front of a cinema screen is just
fundamental to what it means to be human
in the very earliest days of Cinema you
would go to see films in really quite
strange spaces the archways under
Railway stations in markets in shops
often at Fairgrounds so it was quite a
transient thing so in the 1920s the
numbers really start to go up there's
heating comfortable seats you start to
buy ice cream suddenly like this is
quite a nice thing to go and do
[Music]
people would risk life and limb to go
and see films as you would have air raid
sirens going off fire wardens kind of
announcing bombs coming and people would
still sit in the cinema
[Music]
I think stories are one of the things
that makes us fundamentally human and as
a neuroscientist I've always been
interested in how people experience
stories how do these stories affect
people when they're in audiences
[Music]
yeah
we had people in the cinema watching
this film then we also had people in my
lab at UCL watching the film by
themselves
[Music]
what we found is that when you're
watching with an audience there's much
stronger emotional reactions than when
you're watching it alone
when Jasmine and Aladdin kiss for the
first time that is the spike in
electrodermal activity in the signal and
electrodermal activity is the strongest
indicator of emotional engagement
I went to a screening of singing in the
rain and I remember
sitting going into that screening
feeling really quite miserable and the
film came on
and by halfway through I just felt
absolutely elevated and so lifted out of
myself and it's that feeling and it's
that moment that I always come back to
most of the time when you leave the
cinema I feel you know
change in a way whether it's challenged
or whether I feel empowered or wherever
I feel kind of like energized there's a
feeling that it evokes
you're scrolling through your phone
you've got the radio you've got the TV
you're constantly being shouted at by
different voices and unless you can
immerse yourself in that one story
you're not going to be transported in
the way that Cinema intends to transport
you
the lights go out my phone's off and I'm
just so focused on what I'm watching
we live in quite an individualistic
culture and I think whenever we can come
together whether it's a music concert
whether it's a boxing match or whatever
there's almost this ability to move as
one to thinkers one to feel as one one
of the great powers of Cinema is that
it's the means by which we tell each
other about ourselves and it's a means
by which we develop our empathy muscle
which is like it's crucial to becoming
better people and making the world a
better place
[Music]
the energy in there you're in a room
full of strangers but all of you are
going through the exact same experience
at the same time and I think there's
that kind of sacred Bond there
Cinemas haven't always been totally
accessible to everyone and that's a
really important thing for us to think
about in terms of people's well-being
decades ago Cinemas were not necessarily
wheelchair accessible now there are laws
in place that mean they certainly should
be
covid really reminded us of how much we
need each other of how much we are
social animals and of how it is
different watching a film on your own on
your laptop than going to the cinema and
watching it in darkness surrounded by
strangers who are miraculously
experiencing the same thing as you at
the same time I suppose that at some
point they might be superseded by an
even cooler way to give us a story at 3D
Holograms or something but the idea that
we would stop getting together as
audiences to watch a story as a group I
can't see that ever disappearing as long
as they're humans Cinema is the place
where humans go to be reminded of what
it is to be human
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video